o padres ausentes,
que es lo que la gente pudiera pensar de mis padres,
tengo 50 que dicen algo diferente acerca de la misma gente,
presentándose cada día y dando lo mejor de sí.
No digo que algunas de las historias negativas no son ciertas,
pero esas historias nos permiten no ver lo que la gente realmente es,
porque no nos dan el cuadro completo.
La verdades a medias y las tramas limitadas nos han convencido
que los pobres son un problema que necesita arreglarse.
¿Por qué no reconocemos que lo que funciona es la gente
y lo que está roto es nuestra estrategia?
¿Que tal si nos diéramos cuenta que los expertos que estamos buscando,
los expertos que necesitamos seguir,
son la misma gente pobre?
¿Que tal si, en lugar de imponer soluciones,
agregáramos fuego,
a la llama encendida que ya tienen?
No dirigiendo,
ni siquiera empoderando,
sino solo avivando su iniciativa.
Justo al norte de aquí,
tenemos un ejemplo de cómo se podría ver esto:
Silicon Valley.
Toda una industria de capital de riesgo ha crecido alrededor de la creencia
de que si la gente tiene buenas ideas y el deseo de manifestarlas,
deberíamos darles mucho, mucho, mucho dinero.
(Risas)
¿Verdad? ¿Pero dónde está nuestra estrategia para Theresa y Baakir?
No hay incubadoras para ellos,
ni aceleradores, ni hermandades.
¿Cuál es realmente la diferencia entre Jobana, Sintia, Bertha
y los Mark Zuckerbergs del mundo?
Baakir tiene experiencia y trayectoria.
Yo pondría mi dinero en él.
Así que consideren esta una invitación
para revisar una estrategia imperfecta.
Agarremos esta oportunidad
para abandonar una narrativa cansada y defectuosa,
y escuchemos y busquemos historias verdaderas,
historias más hermosamente complejas,
de quienes son la gente, las familias y las comunidades marginadas.
Voy a tomar un minuto para hablar a mi gente.
No podemos esperar
hasta que alguien más haga lo correcto.
Recordemos de lo que somos capaces,
todo lo que hemos construido con sangre, sudor y sueños,
todos los eslabones que siguen dando vuelta,
y la gente que se mantiene a flote gracias a nuestro trabajo agotador.
Recordemos que somos magia.
Si necesitan algo de inspiración para refrescar la memoria,
lean la "Parábola del sembrador"” de Octavia Butler.
Escuchen “"Carta desde la cárcel de Birmingham"” del Reverendo King.
Escuchen a Suheir Hammad recitar "First writing since".
o a Esperanza Spalding ejecutar "“Oro Negro"”.
Echen un vistazo al arte de Kehinde Wiley
o de Favianna Rodriguez.
Miren las manos de sus abuelas
o los ojos de alguien que los ame.
Somos magia.
Individualmente no tenemos mucha riqueza o poder,
pero colectivamente, somos imparables.
Y gastamos mucho de nuestro tiempo y energía
organizando nuestro poder para demandar
cambios de sistemas que no fueron hechos para nosotros.
En lugar de tratar de alterar el tejido de la forma de ser existente,
vamos a entretejer y cortemos una nueva tela más feroz.
Usemos algo de nuestro considerable poder colectivo
para inventar y darle vida
a nuevas maneras de ser que trabajen para nosotros.
Desmond Tutu habla del concepto de Ubuntu,
en el contexto del proceso de verdad y reconciliación de Sudáfrica
en que se embarcaron después del Apartheid.
Dice que significa:
“Mi humanidad está atrapada, está inextricablemente atada a la tuya,
pertenecemos a un bulto de vida”.
Un bulto de vida.
El proceso de verdad y reconciliación comenzó
al elevarse las voces de los no escuchados.
Si este país va a vivir a la altura de su promesa de libertad y justicia para todos,
entonces necesitamos elevar las voces de nuestros no escuchados,
de gente como Jobana, Sintia y Bertha, Theresa y Baakir.
Debemos darle palanca a sus soluciones y sus ideas.
Debemos escuchar sus historias verdaderas,
sus historias más hermosamente complejas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)